ziel des portals ist die reportage zum
thema pelz online mir hand aufzeigt wie
es der markt und führt wo in finnland
konnte werte für das sie pelz kennt wir
sind überwältigt vor euch eine reaktion
es hat sich so viel wie dem video würde
mir sehr gern es bald vor die häufigste
frage beantworten
immer wieder ist fragt warum handelt
denn der trainer und die fans nicht
einfach frech wenn es die hand dazu muss
man sagen die sich illegal und es ist so
dass pechstein gar nicht cool für die
sind nämlich so schwer auf seine großes
gewicht züchtet dass die sich gar nicht
könnte bewegen und je mehr unmöglich
also die würden verhungern und bündig es
so dass das verboten ist ihr dürft nicht
in finnland levels cry heimische tier
und ist zudem als tierschützer wo sich
mit dem thema auseinander gesetzt hat
dass die die stereotype verhaltensweisen
wo sie beschäftige sich auch geeignet
hand nicht einfach und ablecken
also das heißt die hätte es denn immer
noch aber wieder wildnis darum würz
mitbringen
unterschiedliche tierschützer gerettet
und sie gefragt was würdet ihr den
vorschlag was ist denn das was bringe
für tier und so schlimm wie es tönt das
einzige was sinn macht ist didier sanft
zu rasieren und trainerberuf höhere mit
der zucht eine andere frage wohl mal
wieder auftaucht ich wie finde ich den
user dass 80 oder kunstpelz da gibt es
verschiedene indizien auf einer
sitzgruppe die pelze und
auseinanderziehen und wenn die hölle
direktor lada gemacht sind ist
wahrscheinlichkeit groß dass es nicht
gut ist wenn man es klappt sieht dennis
verschiedenen kunstpelz machen einmal
die blase wenn sich die hölle bewegend
ist als wenn sich nicht alle bewegen
kunst und wenn man immer noch unsichere
ist der kamera sporthose und tierarzt
wenn es nach verbranntem horn schmückt
den ist es acht bands und wenn es nach
plastik schmeckt ist es gespenst in der
kommentarspalte taucht auch immer wieder
frei konnte die schweiz
rothfuss pelz vom schweizer rotfuchs
eine alternative sieht so pelz vor dir
und form halte kann der vermieter und
der erzählt dass sie der schweiz 20 bis
30 5 pro jahr
verschlossene jäger immerhin über
gestand heißt also es gibt die fälle
aber die sind beseitigt ist wie jedes
andere stoß das heißt vorarbeit ist
aufwendig und kostet wenn wir weiterhin
zu günstigen produkt wendet wie die
jetzt ab werden denn ist wahrscheinlich
der schweizer rothfuß sky unter native
zu denen tiere aus form halten frage ist
es ist ein netter ist wenn man zwölf
pelz verzichtet aber fleisch ist und das
ist eine interessante frage unter das
niveau macht mit grenze es gibt leute
aus der tierschutz kreise
es ist ok
das bringt ernährt sich der formal wird
sagt man hätte ganze nährstoff und so
weiter also ist es legitim fleisch zu
essen
pelz ist jedem fall jetzt für eine
kaputte andere einfach nur dekoration
und darum geht es gar nicht
das sind so duncan wiese aber es ist
verständlich wenn man seit hotels müsst
ihr sterben für fleisch muss ist ihr
aussterben
also muss man konsequent sie unter 42
deshalb für jede einzelne dort wo man
linie ziert verschiedene zuschauer
selbst fragt gibt eine humane ort zu
tier von pelz züchter dazu gehören mit
biologinnen und mit tierschützern
geredet und gesagt wenn mir das direkt
und das einfach auf der block war sie
verschießt und den pelz braucht dass sie
die 40 breakball
aber alles was kommerziell gemacht wird
die zucht die in der form dass man geld
für das musste ich rechnen muss lukrativ
sie und deutlich sodass dance tirol auf
der strecke bleibt und darum sagt
tierschützer das werk kommerziell möchte
selbst produzieren und dass ich vorne
macht ist dass dirk recht nicht möglich
wir bleiben für euch dran dem thema und
andere themen musik und ohne sorge wenn
ich nicht aufpasse abonnieren doch heute
kanal